bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 l'aktu
de ce mardi 27 mai dans quelques
instants nous allons parler des tableaux
numériques interactifs
ils ont fait leur entrée en force à
l'école c'est bien ou pas nous en
débattrons avec notre invité dans 5
minutes mais d'abord donc les titres
développés ce soir la fronde contre les
rythmes scolaires se poursuit la ville
de versailles avait déjà demandé un
report de l'application du décret le
maire ump françois de mazières propose
maintenant aux parents d'élèves de
signer une pétition
le 49e par le congrès des conseillers
pédagogiques se tient actuellement à
saint quentin en yvelines au coeur des
discussions l'avenir de l'école et les
nouvelles orientations à prendre et puis
le golfe pour tous mille enfants de
montigné de la verrière participent à
des stages d'initiation en vue de la
ryder cup 2018 qui se tiendra au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
mais on ouvre d'abord 7,8 actu rick
cette info du jour
nouvel épisode dans la sphère du
contrôle d'identité de la femme voilée à
trappes
mickaël qui rit le mari condamné à trois
mois de prison avec sursis pour s'être
violemment interposé lors du contrôle
avait fait appel de la décision
il a été jugé ce mardi après midi devant
la 7e chambre correctionnelle du
tribunal de versailles et coups de
théâtre
un nouveau témoin des faits s'est
présenté à la barre une femme habitant
le quartier mermoz a déclaré avoir avoir
vu amical qui rit complètement stoïque
lors de ce contrôle
ce qui va à l'encontre des déclarations
des trois policiers concernés par la
faire le délibéré du jugement est prévu
le 1er juillet l'avocat général a requis
la confirmation de la peine une page
politique pour continuer l affaire
bygmalion ces surfacturations et fausses
factures de congrès tenu par l'ump il
yal'affaire bygmalion donc reprendre
rebondit aussi à dans le département
pierre lequiller député de la 4e
circonscription des yvelines a été
auditionné vendredi dernier par l'office
central de lutte contre la corruption
en tant que témoin libre il a été
interrogé afin de savoir s'il avait ou
non participer à une convention de l'ump
sur le thème de l'europe lé 2 juin 2012
une manifestation présumées fictives
joint par nos confrères du parisien le
député illinois a déclaré qu'il n'avait
aucun souvenir qu'un tel événement ait
eu lieu
des révélations qui vont dans le sens de
jérôme lavrilleux directeur de cabinet
de jean françois copé qui a reconnu un
dérapage sur le nombre d'événements
organisés dans le cadre de la campagne
présidentielle
et puis à noter que nicolas sarkozy
était d'ailleurs venu en mars 2012 à
elancourt lors d'un meeting officiel
inscrit évidemment dans le cadre de la
campagne
allez une page économie pour continuer à
psa peugeot citroën va à délocaliser la
production de sa prochaine génération de
citadine c3 en slovaquie elle est
aujourd'hui fabriqué intégralement à
poissy depuis la fermeture de l'usiné
d'aulnay sous bois son ancien site de
production
la direction rappelle que la pérennité
de l'usiné de poissy n'est pas remise en
cause
on se dirige plutôt vers une
spécialisation dans le segment des
petites voitures haut de gamme selon un
porte parole est les syndicats eux
craignent des coupes dans les effectifs
parmi les 5800 poste en cdi allez les
rythmes scolaires on en reparle avec
cette pétition lancée cette fois par le
maire de versailles françois de mazières
avait demandé le report de l'application
du décret mais sans succès eh bien le
maire ump de versailles en appel
aujourd'hui aux habitants de sa commune
pour qu'ils signent une pétition
pétition mise en ligne sur le site
internet de la ville
on écoute le maire de versailles à
verser 1 il ya quelques années existait
un système qui fonctionnait très bien
c'est à dire qu'il y avait une rythmes
scolaires le samedi matin
un samedi sur deux et tout le monde
était content on a proposé de revenir à
ce système qui convenait bien à la fois
aux parents à la fois aux professeurs
est également une moue sur le plan
budgétaire
et qu'est ce que l'on voit c'est que
cette situation nous est refusé et donc
on se trouve avec
une réforme qui est imposée à nous qu
est une réforme extrêmement verrouillé
de partout et je dirais que en ce moment
vraiment on a besoin d'intelligence où
on a besoin de calme on a besoin que les
finances publiques soient maîtrisés mais
je dis tout simplement versailles et
qu'ils témoignent de leur
incompréhension
nous aussi nous avons vraiment joué le
jeu je dois lui dire j'ai pris contact
personnellement avec le ministre en lui
expliquant puisque il est un ministre
des yvelines et député des yvelines
je lui dis vraiment voilà essayons
d'être intelligent semble ce qui me
navre c'est qu'il ya un décret tellement
bloquant qu'on ne peut pas être
intelligent on ne peut qu être
dogmatique et ceci va à l'encontre de
l'intérêt des enfants de l'intérêt des
professeurs de l'intérêt de la
collectivité puisque ça coûte point
ville comme versailles au minimum de
points d'impôt alors on va continuer à
parler éducation peut-être moins de
polémiques avec vous jean jacques
boilley bonsoir on va parler notamment
des tableaux interactifs et des
tablettes qui se développe de plus en
plus dans les écoles
vous êtes vous représentez un marque de
logiciel et vous allez nous expliquer
tout ça dans quelques instants
et vous participez également au 49e
congrès des conseillers pédagogiques qui
se tient actuellement à saint quentin en
yvelines
je rappelle que le rôle d'un concis
pédagogique c'est d'épauler les
professeurs débutants et d'accompagner
les plus expérimentés c'est évidemment
l'occasion de faire un bilan sur l'école
d'aujourd'hui et les évolutions à venir
de longs applaudissements pour philippe
meirieu venus participer au 49e congrès
national des conseillers pédagogiques
philippe meirieu universitaire celui
pour qui l'éducation doit être une
invention permanente
il est venu livrer sa vision de l'école
d'aujourd'hui et tirer une sonnette
d'alarmé démocratisons l'accès au savoir
que tous les enfants quelle que soit
leur origine sociale quelles que soient
leurs accidents de vie quelles que
soient leurs histoires personnelles
réussissent mieux accéder à ce que les
savoirs ont de plus émancipateur
l'école de la république fonctionne
c'est une belle institution mais on voit
bien qu'elles creusent les écarts
aujourd'hui là où elle devrait les
réduire on voit bien que parfois une
secrète un peu d'ennui là où elle
devrait mobiliser l'énergie et
l'intelligence des élèves depuis
plusieurs années au delà de la détresse
des enfants qui n'ont pas
la possibilité d'apprendre ce qu'il de
gap rendent à l'école publique à l'école
de la république la détresse sociale du
côté des enseignants on a des
enseignants qui perd de plus en plus
conscience des enseignants qui ne sont
plus reconnus c'est vrai que depuis 2013
la nouvelle loi dans fondation de
l'école redonne des perspectives des
perspectives dans une école qui se
modernise avec en ligne de mire l'outil
numérique indispensable ou gadgets
numériques avec votre table mais le tout
écran est-ce qu'il est suffisant pour
apprendre donné à deux armes une
tablette numérique à des enfants de 2
ans est-ce que ça suffit pour qu'ils
puissent construire des représentations
sur le monde qui l'entouré
moi il me semble que redonner la place
aussi peut-être aux échanges au langage
oral dans cette école de demain en
pleine mutation les conseillers
pédagogiques accompagnateurs des
enseignants débutants comme confirmés
ont donc leur mot à dire
ils sont 3000 en france le numérique
c'est indispensable
on va en parler avec jean-jacques voyais
je le dis vous êtes responsable des
relations institutionnelles des éditions
un jeu kata par les éditions akata elles
ont lancé en 1996 le premier logiciel
éducatif adapté alors à l'époque il y
avait pas grand chose en matière
d'ordinateurs et l'informatique dans les
écoles en 96
on va dire un des premiers logiciels mis
sur le marché de du scolaire oui c'était
c'était en 1996 c'est à dire qu'à
l'epoque notre le fondateur de
l'entreprise bruno laroche était un
visionnaire
donc on continue j'espère à l'être
encore maintenant et avait avait
anticipé très largement pensant qu'un
jour il y aurait des ordinateurs dans
les écoles et à l'époque l époque on se
moque un peu de nous pour ne pas dire
pire compte passer pour de joyeuses
allumé en fait je pense que l'avenir
en tout cas le présent nous a donné
raison et aujourd'hui vous équiper 68
on a 60 mille classes d'équipé grosso
modo à la louche c'est peut-être un peu
plus mais en nombre de classes équipées
oui d'un de nos logiciels maternelles et
primaires maternelles et élémentaires
élémentaire quand vous entendez le
président de l'association nationale des
conseillers pédagogiques parlé de
l'importance du numérique mais il dit
aussi également il faut pas donner des
tablettes numériques à des enfants de 2
ans comment vous réagissez
je réagis je pense que de toute façon
marcel jallet qui est un ami en plus
c'est très bien si racontait et mais
peut-être des réserves par rapport à ça
c'est un fait qui a deux en a peut-être
d'autres choses à faire que de s'occuper
d'une tablette numérique
mais d'un autre côté ça fait partie du
quotidien et la question reste à savoir
si à qui il appartient de mettre ça dans
les mains des enfants
à l'heure actuelle tous les dix ans sont
équipés et les enseignants sont
peut-être les derniers dans certains cas
l'utiliser à et à le mettre dans les
mains des enfants donc l'école n'est
plus le lieu où on va initier on va on
va détenir une forme de savoir où on va
aider les enfants à développer des
compétences maintenant la tablette ou
l'ordinateur fait partie de
l'environnement quotidien à dos des
familles pas de toutes les familles et
bien contrairement à ce qu'on peut
penser même dans des familles qui sont
en situation difficile j'en parlais ce
matin encore au cours d'une intervention
avec une conseillère pédagogique
d'elancourt elle me disait qu'elle avait
été surprise d'arriver avec sa tablette
dans une école où les enfants sont
arrivés en lisant mon papa à sa maman
est la même c'était dans un milieu
plutôt défavorisés alors quand vous
dites que l'économie
n'est plus initiateurs ça veut dire que
quoi le col a peur d avance je pense que
l'école n'a peur de rien parce qu'il
faut remettre les choses à leur place
c'est parler des outils tant qu'on parle
d'outils numériques un outil il faut
qu'il ya quelqu'un pour s'en servir
jusqu'à preuve du contraire donc
l'enseignant est tout à fait capable et
tout à fait maître est tout à fait en
plus compétent pour l'utiliser et pour
le mettre au service d'une pédagogie ce
qui est important c'est ça l'outil où
lui-même ne vaut rien une tablette si
vous la laissez ou un ordinateur ça va
rien faire tout seul rosie oui
heureusement à vous votre parcours est
intéressant parce que pendant 32 ans
vous avez été enseignant en ils
s'envoient sais pas si c'est une belle
région
c'est ce que vous m'aviez dit content
après par l'entretien réalisé des
enseignants en haute savoie pendant 32
ans
quand vous avez enseigné vous avez vous
allez penser avant d'emmener que
justement l'informatique les tableaux
numériques interactifs ou et prendre
autant de place autant d'importance
il était évident dès 1985 plan
informatique pour tous que l'ordinateur
allait rentrer à l'école il est arrivé
où se forme de théo 7 70 ces mots cinq
qui étaient des machines on va dire
qu'ils feraient rire maintenant mais qui
au moins ont donné le virus a certains
dont je fais partie et je suis vraiment
pas le seul c'est comme ça vous avez
fait la bascule pour dire non non c'est
de venir intégrer un nom en fait j'ai
été auteur en tant qu'enseignant hauteur
au sein des éditions joca top
et puis ensuite je suis venu à temps
complet pour pour y travailler en tant
que responsable des relations
institutionnelles
que pensez-vous de l'utilisation des
tennis à l'école les fameux tableau
numérique interactif
elle c'est la question que nous sommes à
aller vous poser aujourd'hui dans les
rues de saint quentin en yvelines on
écoute vos réponses je pense que ça peut
être bien si c'est bien utilisé c'est
bien présenté j'aimerais bien que mes
petits enfants apprennent un peu comment
comme moi j'ai appris c'est plutôt utile
oui ça peut être un nouveau support et
aider les profs aussi a évolué dans
leurs cours pour les enfants
non c'est timide reste à la crèche pense
je pense que toute façon les enfants
sont plus attentifs à ce mode de
communication parce qu'ils aiment mais
par contre au niveau fatigue des yeux
mode de communication c'est bien de
continuer avec avec le support papier et
la réflexion et l'écriture il faut vivre
avec son temps je pense que c'est
dommageable mais jusque malheureusement
ne peut pas aller contre ce qu'on
appelle le progrès bon le foie gras
saddam à la parole beaucoup apprécié le
projet qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette réflexion de cette dame qui dit
oui c'est bien il faut aller de l'avant
mais faut pas oublier non plus
l'expression écrite l'expression orale
je pense que d'abord sa réflexion lui
appartient la tout à fait le droit de
penser ce qu'elle veut deuxième chose je
ne vois pas où est l'incompatibilité
dans la mesure où on peut utiliser un
tableau numérique un ordinateur une
tablette pour pour que cet outil soit au
service de l'acquisition de compétences
de connaissances auprès des enfants
vous avez dit vous avez animé ce matin
une conférence à elancourt avec des
enseignants est en cours je rappelle
celle des conseillers pédagogiques
conseil pédagogie et elles ont coursé
une vie des pionniers en tout cas soit
sur le bassin de 50 ans jean l'ensemble
des classes est équipé en tableaux
numériques quel regard portent ces
enseignants justement sur cette nouvelle
nouvelles technologies ça y est c'est
complètement intégrée à qui j'ai parlé
oui bien sûr bien sûr et puis aussi des
conseillers pédagogiques parc
particulièrement efficace qui est qu'il
les aide qui les conduisent pas ce qu'il
faut savoir que c'est très très très
chronophage d'utilisation de ces outils
d'où l'intérêt d'avoir des maisons
d'édition qui ont des chronos phase
c'est-à-dire pour je sais pas pour une
heure pour une heure d'utilisation papa
par une heure à la suite avec des élèves
on aura peut-être peut-être trois heures
de préparation pour fabriquer son
document alors ça veut dire quoi que
l'évolution des logiciels doivent
justement aider ces enseignants alors
alors préparez le travail ça veut dire
ça c'est notre notre métier c'est ce
qu'on propose deux éditions joca top
c'est d'avoir de proposer des supports
qui vont aider les enseignants n'ont pas
faire leur travail mais leur fournir une
belle caisse caisse à outil qui
fonctionne très très bien pour pour
mettre ça au service de l'enseignement
de leur travail pour le bien des enfants
qu'on oublie souvent à travers tout ça
on parle de beaucoup de choses jamais de
l'intérêt de l'élève
donc si l'élève on intérêt pour l'élève
celle et au delà d'avoir une pédagogie
comme ça vient un tableau interactif
plutôt qu'une pédagogie de jaar je pense
qu'au niveau de la pédagogie ça va rien
changer
la pédagogie c'est l'art et la manière
de faire passer des choses les présenter
et puis surtout surtout de susciter
l'intérêt et à l'heure actuelle pour
susciter l'intérêt passer par un écran
je pense que c'est quelque chose d'assez
évident vous comprenez les réticences
mais bien sûr parce que tout ce qui est
nouveau fait toujours fait peur c'est
pas ça va non à l'époque où le train est
arrivé en france sur les médecins
certains médecins disaient que le coeur
ne supporterait pas une vitesse
supérieure à 30 km valeur avec les tgv
qu'est ce que ce serait
aujourd'hui c'est comment quelles sont
les évolutions en matière de logiciels
justement interactif et ce qu'ils
doivent devenir un peu plus intuitif un
peu plus facile d'accès parce que au
départ ça fait un peu je veux dire ça
mais au départ les enseignants avaient
un peu des craintes sur l'utilisation
sur excel en disant comment on va faire
est-ce qu'on va savoir
ils ont raison parce que on va toucher à
ce moment là le problème de la formation
c'est à dire se servir d'un outil c'est
bien mais il faut avoir appris donc le
rôle de l'éditeur l'encore ça va être de
fournir des outils qui vont être les
plus intuitif possible qu'ils vont qui
ne vont pas demande énormément de
travail de la part d'enseignants pour
l'aider à mener sa mission
d'enseignement où justement les
logiciels que vous proposez combien de
temps pour pour les développer et qui
les développent alors au départ nous
tous nos auteurs sont des enseignants en
activité des gens qui sont dans des
classes première chose deuxièmement on a
une équipe éditoriale une équipe de
développement en interne avec
programmeurs infographiste et puis par
exemple dernier produit le son numérique
de science ça représente le travail à
temps complet de cinq personnes pendant
six mois plus une année de préparation
de la part de l'auteur enseignants qui
nous a fait le cahier des charges
un enseignant n'aurait pas pu faire ça à
lui même il peut le faire à condition de
voilà de ne pas regarder ce qui va faire
le week-end de mercredi de façon les
enseignants travaillent beaucoup redore
j'en sais quelque chose
mais là ça devient totalement surhumain
alors qu'on en fasse un peu de temps en
temps oui mais je ne connais pas de
chirurgie
ayant forgé son bistouri tout à fait
vous avez été enseignant pendant 32 ans
quel regard vous portez sur l'école
d'aujourd'hui et celle de demain le même
que sur l'école d'hier c'est à dire que
c'est je pense qu enseignant juin avant
l'édition scolaire c'est quand même le
plus beau métier du monde
à mon avis et ensuite je pense pas que
ce soit foncièrement différent je ne
crois pas même les outils seront
différents les outils sont différents
mais tout à l'heure une personne parlait
dans votre reportage de l'utilisation du
tableau de la craie mais quelle
différence est ce qu'il y à entre écrire
avec une craie sur un tableau vert ou
noir ait pu utiliser un tableau
numérique
la différence c'est que le tableau
numérique on va pouvoir conserver la
mémoire de ce qu'on avait écrit alors qu
autrement quand on effacés et bien ça
c'est fini il faut s'adapter
merci beaucoup d'employés sont pas dotés
merci merci beaucoup
allez on poursuit aussi avec un sujet
éducation mais cette fois-ci de
l'éducation par le sport est la ryder
cup 2018 ce sera au golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines
en attendant mille enfants de montigny
le bretonneux et de la verrière
apprennent à manier un club
reportage anthony rech patrick jacques
de dixmude au practice au petit nous
encore au coude approche pour la
première fois ses enfants de la verrière
manit un club de golf faut bien se
concentrer d'abord et un tir
et aussi après si on rate cette journée
de sensibilisation permettent aux
enfants de développer des compétences
spécifiques comme la motricité la
concentration des qualités
indispensables pour contrôler la balle
c'est aussi l'occasion de changer les a
priori sur la discipline
pas besoin d'un parcours huppé pour
faire quelques swings
à l'heure actuelle il existe des golfs
du coin et des gauches 3 et 4 étoiles
donc le but du jeu c'est pas que tout le
monde fasse du golfe dans les 4 étoiles
mais ben c'est d'ouvrir la porte à
chacun comme on a en angleterre ou mal à
vous avez un champ vous avez un drapeau
vous avez un départ et puis et puis
c'est parti
et c'est comme ça que bon nombre de
joueurs se sont formés mais cette
journée découverte ne s'arrête pas là la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines a mis en place
l'opération collaboration avec la
direction départementale de l'éducation
nationale
l'autre objectif c'est de promouvoir un
projet un peu plus comme un peu plus
globale pardon de un projet pédagogique
autour du golf c'est à dire que là c'est
pour que les enseignants et les élèves
puissent puissent initier et ensuite on
propose aux enseignants de sur une
formation pour qu'ils puissent faire un
cycle de psa en classe les enseignants
auront à leur disposition des kits
pédagogiques pour intégrer le module
d'apprentissage du golfe dans les
programmes scolaires
près de mille enfants de montigné de la
verrière vont pouvoir effectuer leurs
premiers swings et peut-être faire
partie du public de la ryder cup 2018
sur le golf national et peut-être des
futures graines de champions aller mille
personnes sont venues au sein de mont
boron à versailles participé aux
olympiades du vivre ensemble objectif
porter un autre regard sur le handicap
sur le bord du terrain
car combien julien leroy
thibault lebrun et malvoyants mais cela
ne l'a pas empêché de devenir sportif de
haut niveau son sport de prédilection le
showdown un mélange de jeu de palets et
de billard l'objectif marquer des buts
en se servant des bords dans la balle
des billes d'acier permettent aux
joueurs de visualiser le jeu à l'oreille
samedi dernier il participait aux
olympiades du vivre ensemble une journée
d'animations sportives ouvertes à tous
valides ou handicapés jeunes et moins
jeunes
une initiative de l'association
départementale de parents et amis de
personnes handicapées mentales et de la
ville de versailles
c'est un apport autant pour pour tous
les sports que pour la diversité parce
que beaucoup d'handicapés se renferme
sur eux mêmes et à je trouve que
justement c'est une très bonne
initiative qu'on puisse vraiment
s'ouvrir sur le monde
le sport un facteur de lien social le
shodan encore méconnu est originaire du
canada
c'est un sport qui vient du canada qui a
été
créé par un athlète canadien qui était
pongistes et qui est devenu aveugle qui
a créé le showdown dans l'intention de
créer un sport
pour les déficients visuels sans l'aide
de voyants à quelques pas de là
handicapés et valides s'initier à la
moto un sport qui rassemble tous les
publics
c'est bien mais c'est dire de tourner
par contre je trouve ça un peu dans les
dents la boutique était mais sinon est
ce que ma moto mais je veux dangereux
puisque deux autres avec du vivier
toujours sur deux roues certains tests
des vélos adaptés
d'autres découvrent le chambard à sport
japonais
on ne compte que 1518 licenciés en
france pour la fédération ces olympiades
sont une occasion d'attirer de nouveaux
adhérents
c'est de la mousse donc déjà ce sont des
armes inoffensive et notion de distance
appréhender justement pour pas se
baisser donc à aucun contact physique
ça demande un peu de synchronisation des
mouvements des rangs des bras et des
jambes ce qui fait que pour les
personnes en situation de handicap c'est
tout à fait adapté et justement ils vont
apprendre la synchronisation apprendre à
se déplacer dans l'espace et apprendre à
gérer la distance avec leurs partenaires
un sport original qui a attiré de
nombreux participants comme stéphane
plus habitué à tenir un ballon de rugby
c'est bien ça apprend à combattre ça va
je me débrouille pas trop mal
pourtant accueillir des personnes
handicapées n'est pas toujours une chose
aisée pour les clubs et sportifs
3 compte que c'est pas toujours facile
que ça soit pour les installations
le truc tout bête pratique c'est qu'à la
mairie par exemple on a eu du mal à
faire accepter le fait et des fauteuils
qu'ils puissent venir sur le parquet par
exemple donc c'est pas toujours il ya
toujours toujours un petit problème les
mentalités changent peu à peu près de
mille personnes ont participé à cette
cinquième édition des olympiades du
vivre ensemble
un succès qui permet d'année en année
que le sport dépasse tous les clivages
piquage repiquage bouturage des noms qui
évoquent le jardinage en cette période
propice aux plantations le centre
horticole du tremblay sur mauldre a
proposé des ateliers d'initiation et des
ateliers qui s'inscrivait dans le cadre
de l'opération départementale parole de
jardiniers une fête dédiée donc à la
nature et jérémy et brasse aux
commentaires avisés
quoi de mieux que le jour de la fête de
la nature pour apprendre ou se
perfectionner en jardin
âge c'est ce que proposait le centre
horticole de l'enseignement et de la
promotion du tremblay sur mauldre le
chef dispensés par exemple un atelier de
rempotage
donc on commence par d'abord prendre un
contenant qui va correspondre aux
besoins de la plante pourtant on a un
contenant qui fait 2 litres va ensuite
disposer le terreau dans le contenant
hauteur d'environ la moitié de ceux
comptant ensuite nous allons venir
chercher le lupin donc le diarra signer
le plus près cautionnement possible pour
pour essayer d'avoir dire d'avoir des
racines qui sont intactes j'ai appris
des jacobins rempoter un lupin ce qui
était intéressant et je savais pas c'est
le principe du paillage quand vous avez
l'esprit crise que c'était pas si du
voyage et à mon avis on peut gagner du
temps un choc
le paillage consiste à mettre un feutre
blanc juste en surface pour avoir donc
une matière organique qui va permettre
de ne pas avoir de mauvaises herbes et
de retenir un maximum d'humidité les
experts sont là pour prodiguer des
conseils pour les partisans du bouturage
cette technique de clonage des plantes
voici le bons gestes à adopter bien
coupé la bouture sous un oeil et au
dessus de l'oeil voilà en termes de
bouturage
lorsqu'on parle là on parle de boutures
deux moutures de tronçons et si la météo
lunatique de ces derniers jours vous
embête
pensez à vos fleurs l'alternance de
pluie et de soleil est idéal pour leur
épanouissement 6-7-8 là qu est terminé
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite
vous avez rendez vous avec le 7-8
politique présentée par wilshere richy
qui reçoit l'eurodéputée ump constante
le gris pour faire le point sur ces
élections bonne soirée à bientôt